do you have the updated docs
probably just talk
cbs
okay
okay
let's see well for people joining this
it's a design review of something that i
thought think will be straightforward
but who knows
um which is the functions file name join
and file name partition no file join and
file partition
okay so let's start off with file
partition
okay so first of
all um
why do these exist
why do these exist
i how are you asking i i thought that
was a rhetorical question
no i'm not going to why do these exist
why did we not use it
to to break up typically large files
into
yeah when you download large files
or upload large files you may want to
split them okay but so
what does the typical code fragment look
like
do you understand my masking
yeah so
for example you have a large file like a
video
and you want to put it up okay so
you would do file partition of the file
name
and
yes i understand all of this but but i'm
i'm asking
what is the bigger workflow okay so so
why are you doing that you're doing it
because you're going to send them an
email or why are you doing that
do you understand my question
yeah
yeah so yeah one one example is for
example sending my email yeah
or
for example you want you you want to put
the file on to
a storage
which doesn't
is not large enough
i'm just not seeing this i'm not
understanding
i mean
in other words what you expect i'm
somebody's microphone you suggested but
um
what
you know are you expecting
that some kind of send mail
blah blah blah blah blah
over
file partition of such and such a file
is that a typical case
and good luck on reassembling that
gender hey whoever's whoever's got their
microphone adjusted in some crazy way
where it's clicking a bunch please
please fix that
okay so do you understand what i'm
asking
okay so what's the answer
so
you know i think our node was the one
who who pushed for this is he not here
i think that reassembling them
can be done obviously we have file join
if you want to do it in the wolfram
language but i think other tools can
reassemble these files
they're just
streaming bytes
okay
so by the way todd i think it's your
microphone that's that's somehow bizarre
oh really i
yeah that's where it does
all right well i'm gonna call back in
then
okay everything
seems normal here i'm gonna call back in
okay
okay
let's take a look at what this does now
not a very useful description right
and that's not the way we write these
you know that right
we don't use we don't do that sort of
punnery
no no no okay so
where does it put the file
so um
the idea is that you the result is a
directory containing parts
okay and if you don't provide directory
then
you have a template
okay into multiple file
splits file into multiple file parts
um
in a temporary directory
is that right
come back
it creates as it creates temporary
directory with
so it's not
it doesn't just dump them into the
directory
but
well we're going to say that although
it's not clear what the heck it does
todd there's something wrong with your
microphone
something is is too close to you or some
such other thing because we keep on
hearing
noise are you hearing like breath and
noises no i'm hearing something no i'm
just through hearing clunking around
noise
occasionally um
a few days ago
the the fanciest apple airpods
apparently do not have orientation very
clearly defined for them and so you can
end up putting them so that they are
listening to the back of your head
that's more like understanding sounded
like
um
i'll go to speakerphone if i sound
better
okay
it could say split files into multiple
file parts into a new temp trajectory
okay
all right but i'm still trying to
understand what this is for
todd
i don't know what's going on but we keep
on hearing
and whatever
i don't know it's just my
well something something is
just perfectly quiet here no use your
headset or whatever or you know i don't
know what
okay look i don't understand the point
of this function really
so um
one limit so i currently i see two
two places where this is done
one is when you zipper file
you can provide you can ask the zip uh
the zip program to split them to chunks
okay
uh and obviously places some information
there another one is as you mentioned
that's email which limits the outgoing
of the size of the attached file
so
what people really want i mean
you know we don't have a kind of
download manager that we can
automatically attach to a file in our
cloud
right but that will be the kind of thing
that is the real workflow here that's
needed
am i making sense
it would do that under the
hood i'm sorry what yeah i
would
split the file and download
separate chunks from parallel yeah i
mean to me this is the thing
isn't there a unix utility that does
this what's it called
it's called split or something do you
know what i'm asking
yeah
have you ever used it
i've used it like once in 40 years
yeah here it is split split a file into
pieces
okay
okay i've i've used it once in some kind
of ancient computing situation
i don't know if can we get did did
anybody find our node
no yeah we're trying
also please don't use a dos file name
when you run the example
think of the future
okay no dos file names
what does it do if the file is what does
it do
if the size
splits a unicode character
it is splitting binary files so we don't
analyze whether that's
unique or not
so it should say that in the
documentation
am i making sense
yes it provides by yeah it's a splits
into binary chunks
it treats the file as the binary
yeah yeah
now
i assume no please don't do this you
know not to do this right
we don't use this kind of capitalization
who looked at these examples
[Music]
right that convention is not something
that we like to use
okay please don't do it
but i want to know how did this get
reviewed
okay
as far as i'm concerned this is an
unidentified flying function that we've
just received here
right i i remember that this function
was talked about a variety of times
okay the fact that we have a custom
meeting specifically for this function
and nobody really knows why it exists is
not a great sign
well let's review it and
file practitioner is relatively
straightforward there's some questions
about file join
okay
okay but i still want to know why it
exists because i'm telling you my sense
says that there is a larger function
that is more like a download manager
that is making use of this
do you see what i'm saying
right but that that's something would be
embedded in the cloud no no no no no i'm
i'm saying i'm trying to understand
what
i mean
um
sky on
our live stream comments that splitting
into parts is a redundant
um
actually you know what come on guys we
use the term file partition
right why do we say split if the if the
term why aren't we calling it file split
if it's splitting
split is better
but we can't call it file split because
split means something completely
different
see what i'm saying
okay this is this is an inadequate
review guys
we don't know why we're doing this
we're just flapping around
we have discussed this pair of functions
before i mean when constantine went to
embark on this it was not
just uh
you know i know i know i know but but
when
um puts
again this is a very weird thing because
the fact that it's creating a temporary
directory that has the name file
partition
and it's creating a temporary directory
is very weird
what other thing what other function
that is called file anything monkeys
around creating directories
[Music]
that there's the create intermediate
directories option
for things like
you know copying files
uh
yes but that's different that's
different this is
this says i mean this name is just wrong
i think
okay
so because what's happening here what
what is this really doing this is
turning a file into a directory of files
right
and then this is going to take a
directory
and reconstitute that into files
so this thing here
what do we want to say call this it's
like create
because again things that create things
on the file system are few and far
between
do you see what i'm saying i mean this
sounds like a function that is like all
of our other well let's just look at
what the other file star functions are
yeah nothing else here okay file convert
okay file convert i does i agree does
that just like export does that am i
making sense
right but nothing else
takes a file
you see what i'm saying
yeah so but that's a
different action different function so
i'm sorry what's a different function
so
uh
for this function is quite logical it
seems logical to
well
that's what it does to create a
directory i know i know i understand i'm
saying a function with a name file
partition doesn't sound like it's
creating a directory
do you understand what i'm saying
it's it's unlike i mean file convert it
makes perfect sense it's going to create
a converted file
okay
i mean that's a mouthful but it does say
what it does
okay because this isn't the right name
this is obscure it does not mean the
right thing
todd what are you doing with audio what
are you doing it's driving me absolutely
crazy
i must have a bad connection because i'm
literally not no you don't have a bad
connection it's just you know i can try
and imitate it
i don't know what you hear there
it's that type of thing
okay
i'm literally
not moving okay well then i don't know
what's going on
okay
it will be great if we actually had some
thinking going on here
okay because this isn't it
this doesn't make any sense
there's several aspects stephen do you
not
there's the name do you think
there's whether we
desire to have a function like this in
the system or not and then and then
there's
the question of what it should be named
yes
and whether this is the right design i
mean i thought this was going to be a
function of positive function wasn't it
how did it get to be not a function
repository function
i'm sure
go ahead there was a prototype started
a while ago and it was not a repository
function
that's one thing
[Music]
right didn't it come out of ild it
didn't
the prototype for this a while back
it was on the backlit
okay you know what this is really
confused let's look at file join
what is a partial file
what does that mean
what is a partial file it's a file right
what order does it put them in how does
it decide what order to put these in
yes or no
i'm sorry
what sorts them but different file
systems sort files in different orders
no vly on sort function so which sort
function our sort function
function on its names not lexicographic
sort for example all the names yep
not numeric sort not lexicographic sort
so how does file partition name the
files
do you understand my question yes
what's the answer so there is an example
no i don't i don't want to know the
example i want to see how it does it
okay if that's how it does it
there's a brain disconnection here
come on think about this if there's more
than 10 of these it's going to sort
wrong isn't it
no no it's not
no
it will number them
what are you talking about what are you
talking about if i take the strings
one
one zero
you know no no it's not like that no it
will have zero zero zero one and so on
why am i not seeing this why am i seeing
this well because the father have five
parts
four points
where is it documented here
right i don't see it documented
is this going to be used by another
program you've got to document that
right
there it's a fourth note
what does that mean what does that mean
the fact that you're generating
no that says there are three characters
here
well so there are as many characters as
needed i know that but you didn't say
that
right
and what is the sequential counter what
does that mean
zero one two three uh what is it where
does it start with zero why does it
start with zero
i don't think it should start with zero
in fact it's a really bad idea for it to
start with zero that means that the nth
element of the list is not the file
dot dot dot dot n you see what i'm
saying
yes but you're not
interested in
ann's part
you might be you might be why wouldn't
you be
you're probably not interested in
anything
why start from zero we don't want to
start from zero we want to start from
one so you can extract the nth part
see what i'm saying
okay
right but continue is there some
are other tools like
what's the
there's a unix
split
function it must be a join function
can it work with the file name if that
probably starts at zero right no the
join is cat the joining for eunuchs is
cat catinate
but is there
but a split has a stylized naming
convention for the parts
no but it did okay
doesn't it okay so if you read what what
split does you learn that it splits
okay okay it actually is a splitting
function
right that knows what it's splitting
it's not just doing a bitewise split
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah
this is the line wise split which to me
is much more useful than a bitewise
split
see what i'm saying
right
well this this has a byte count and it
has a line count but what's more
important is it by default appears to
split at lines
do you understand what i'm saying
these are binary files so there's no
lines there's no column i mean there may
be
i understand but if we're actually going
to use this function it's going to be
used to do things like what i was asking
at the beginning here is what is this
function for
so if i explain that can i explain that
because yes but but i i want to give an
example
let's say you have an apache log and you
want to analyze it in pieces no that's
not what it was originally for okay well
then it's got the wrong name
okay what was it originally for we have
a download manager right i know
that has can i
yes right we have a download manager
that
transfers
very big files four gigabyte files right
what that download manager does it
splits it up into of pieces yep that's
what these two functions were yeah
like binary files
so we can sort of make sure we can write
to download manager so we can write to
download manager that was two two years
ago that was the original reason you
know to write these functions nothing
else no no line nothing with text files
nothing with apache logs just you know
by hand i understand to write to
download manager okay so that was what i
said at the beginning of this meeting i
said
these functions look like they're
relevant to creating a download manager
what would be involved in giving the
wrapping to actually make what is the
closest to a download manager other than
just the amusement of writing a download
manager
what what
we have the paclod system right which
has bigger and bigger files in it binary
files zip files right that are getting
into the you know one two three gigabyte
file sizes yep right
we cannot use the download manager for
that because that's a separate piece of
software right so we could have these
functions in the wolfram language
and and use that to split up these files
absolutely absolutely but my question is
what is the bigger
sort of computation unit
of creating a download manager
see what i'm saying if that's what we're
really trying to do with these why don't
we do that
or at least understand how we're going
to yeah functions together and you need
these two functions i mean i know that
but what does it look like what is the
bigger thing that is you know
if you have these things then you should
be able to do import or get right on a
specific file type right that is sort of
like a
you know file dot with some extension
like a wolfram language right
like like partial archive
and and it would fit you know it would
internally figure out you know how to
download the pieces and you know
re-custom let's talk about but that's
not what we currently have because we
don't currently have a wrapper you know
if what we had was some kind of wrapper
that meant
this is a
a a file parts directory
okay and we could then feed that into
import yeah instead of file of whatever
we could say something like you know
something like um
a file parts not a good name but file
parts directory blah yeah we could say
import that
yeah so that it would import that thing
that has a standardized collection of
file parts that would be one way to do
that but i'm not sure that's quite what
we need what let's walk through what we
actually need
okay but that that is the idea of the
download ministry it does exactly that
like if there's a client i know
fragments yeah i know i know that i know
that i know that i know that i mean the
thing that
what it looks like to the user right a
standard download manager
is creating an installer it's assembling
a dmg file or whatever else correct
yeah that's one part of what it does the
other part is that it there's tooling on
the server side to actually split those
files up and save them you know i know
i know i know that
i know that but from the point of view
of the user let's look through what the
workflow is that involves a user
creating so let's say
that a user says
i'm going to provide this
for example in the cloud okay they might
say i want this file to be downloaded
with a download manager
i'm making sense
i put this big image i want it to be
that or in the data repository i put
this big data thing i want to be
downloaded with the download manager
okay so now what does that look like
now on the server side
something is
i mean on the server side
has used file partition or something
like it to make a directory of files
okay
on the client side
that requires that let's say it's
resource data is the function being used
okay so it could be the case that under
the hood resource data has split some
files into things and you'll see a
download manager that would require a i
mean right now the download manager that
we have puts up essentially browser
level windows that says your file is
being downloaded right
the alternative would be
and i don't know whether we have this
this tooling yet
that you have progress monitor level
things in a notebook
yeah i mean what what you could do here
with the import statement is you can
just see you know there can be a
temporary cell below it that basically
says like exactly downloading
one of a hundreds exactly exactly but
i'm asking the question what we need is
a more general version of that right
because what you're saying is
that that a whole variety of things
you're imagining take the resource take
the data repository as an example okay
you've got a a four gigabyte data set
okay
okay so the obvious thing that would be
nice to be able to do
is to tell the data repository actually
make this downloaded through a download
manager
okay and then the way that download
manager would look is it's a piece of
internal tooling
that
will cause that thing to pop up
when you say resource data
to call that thing that has the download
manager the download manager would
expose itself
through one of those blue progress
monitor boxes
right
yeah
and then what would come back is just
the the you know the assembled file yeah
the only thing that i think is at the
user level from an involved from
language i would just you know i
wouldn't call it download manager just
you know for for user stuff should just
be able to say import
important i agree i agree i agree but i
want to walk through
what it's going to take so a user wants
to use this facility right
okay
so
the issue is
that they're going to point the okay so
let's say they put it in the cloud
okay
the obvious thing to do is to have a
directory
whose name
is something whose mime type
causes
our system to use the downloader you
know the fragment assembler
you know as it brings the stuff over it
is running the fragment assembler rather
than just you know running uh you know
url ready
did you understand what i'm saying i
understand what you're saying i'm not
sure if that's easily possible but i
understand right them setting the mime
type or some sort of like in the headers
that get returned the the response
headers
right it would read that and check that
and then right so so one use case here
is that you have put on the on the web
somewhere it could be in our cloud could
be somewhere else you've put on the web
a
a collection of file fragments
right
i mean we could call it some
uh
you know so the directory would be
uh let's see where am i saving this
um
any clue where i save this where should
i save this didn't find a good folder
for it i was gonna suggest creating a
new one for like file operations or file
functions
all right
okay so so let's go through this again
what it is we're really trying to do
okay so the first thing is
a
file fragments directory
the fundamental unit here what we've got
is a file fragments directory of some
kind correct yeah but i i agree with
that that that's where you store the
just the bits and pieces and i
originally had that with uuids i think
somebody changed it to numbering but you
know it's just
um
okay okay so let's say
i don't know a well-formed formula
uh file fragments
dot wfff for example let's say
our file fragments well i don't know
what we want to call them i mean i think
we need a we need something we can't
call it generically unless somebody else
has another name for this i think that's
good that's that's a good
i like that that's good okay so then
this is a directory name dot woof
woof woof
um
uh
and then in that directory will be the
fragments
right and sander is commenting and i
don't disagree with this
that
that one could have a thing called file
fragments
that has file names in it that are
treated where file fragments returns a
file fragments
is something which in import
um
you know
it
uses a download manager then assembles
itself
that's possible yeah i'm not sure that's
okay but then then what happens here
and and i can imagine
like
file system map
i wonder what it should do on a woof
see file system map
could treat
a woof as a single thing
if you understand what i'm saying
right for example one could imagine for
this woof
that um
uh
i'm not sure where you're going with
this
for example let's say um file byte count
if you give file byte count a woof
maybe it should figure out the file byte
count of all the pieces together
uh yeah
probably yes it would certainly be
useful to do that
okay so then the idea would be
if you say
import a woof
well now what will it look like it'll be
something like this it would be
something like
file.jpg
dot woof
is that true
if you've got a directory of
jpegs um
[Music]
yeah i mean
right that's that's that's a question i
think that's i think it's a good thing
to do i mean that's like what happens
with zip isn't it
doesn't zip to that
not necessarily if you have a jpeg file
then you just give it a name like you
know foo dot zip
the file name doesn't necessarily i
thought there was a convention that you
often put the uh
well zip is an archive right it's an
archive format right so that that stores
an index of the
individually named files i think so
that's different so it's not clear
whether we want to do this okay
so
um
okay
so now you may want to i mean if you
have like you know like a four gigabyte
jpeg right then then maybe that's right
and you want to indicate that the
resulting assembled thing as a jpeg yeah
that's what i'm saying right i think
it's useful and i think it's a i think
it's generally desirable because this
thing will come the woof
will come from a file
right
yeah whereas
it comes from multiple files a woof
comes from a single file
uh yes typically yeah not not typically
we gotta decide i think it comes from a
single file um
that's it okay that's what it's doing
okay
okay single file yeah
okay
so now let's look at what this actually
looks like so then
we are importing
okay
so the whole point would be
okay hold on a second um
ethan is commenting on giant nested
directories of images that need to be
moved across machines but i think that's
a different thing
that's a copy file story and that's not
what we're dealing with here right
right right right that that's
i mean this is purely about
single large files like if you have
multiple files then that's a different
thing
right
okay so now let's understand and then
just
the reason for it is right that it's
unreliable sometimes when you have a
four gigabyte file right these things
exactly
you want it to resume like you want to
be able to close your laptop right after
two gigabytes open it at home or at work
right and it just resumes what's the it
yeah in other words if you had an import
the download of the fragments and the
reassembling of those fragments no but i
understand that i understand that but
but if let's say you're running import
okay
and you should close your laptop
yep okay
in the middle of a four gigabyte
download no no i i
wait a second there's no download
it is just you used import import behind
the scenes
is downloading four gigabyte file
okay
you shut down your machine
you you put
you put things to sleep
it comes back to life again
i don't even know what that does right
now what does that do right now if i'm
in the middle if i
well
if i typically don't just fail at that
point
hold on hold on what does it actually do
i'm running the kernel i'm running a
file import
i sleep my machine at that moment i
bring it back to life again what happens
i think you just get an error i mean i
have to test it but i think you just get
notified at that point because because
right you lose that connection and i
would think you'd get an error i think
you get an error it doesn't obviously
knows it yeah okay
yeah
so i mean this is restartable
file download that's the key thing
that's why we got the download manager
for these you know product downloads i
understand i i understand that i
understand that so
and but that means that what has to be
happening is behind the scenes this has
to be caching into some local file
right yeah as you're doing this right it
saves those files it every time it
downloads a fragments it saves that
fragment into a local uh you know local
place like you know
right what's the relationship then to
local cache
i don't know what local um
local cache takes a file name
and if you wrap local cache around the
file name it makes sure that that file
exists locally
if that file exists lo
the first time it sees it it caches it
it's it's like once
okay but for a file well that sounds
similar except that local cache right
would have the problem that it's if that
the thing you're caching is very big
right and that's the same same problem
right it's
local cache probably downloads did one
go as well just like import does so it's
the same as
import know local cache probably just
just
uses import internally
um
yes yes it does it doesn't or url
download or whatever
okay so the other thing we could use
which is
which i think is a term is multi-part
file
right that's similar to file fragments
yeah that's
yeah i'm not too familiar with that i
think that's an http
yeah what is that i've seen that before
i've seen it in email as well
i don't know if that's
i don't know i don't know i don't know
okay so let's take a look then again
let's take a look at what we're actually
doing so okay so let's say you want to
prepare
you want to turn a file into a woof
okay
so the functions functions needed
right so one thing is turn
a file
into a woof
okay
and that is what essentially file
partition is trying to do
yeah
okay
now one thing that's nice about this if
the default name is dot wfff
um
then
it gets automatically then the file
joining
is automatically done by functions like
import presumably
right in other words if you say import a
woof
blah blah blah
dot woof
then import knows and by the way it's a
good reason to have jpeg.wolf because
then we can use the same logic for
import
to understand what it should do with
that file but this just says oh by the
way it's going to be downloaded from
fragments
right it's a
right that would that would point to the
directory that has the fragments and
then once you've assembled the fragments
it's a jpeg file so that's the final
step
right sandra is commenting it'd be nice
if the fragments contain the name of
other fragments
and some md5 hash to check that it's not
damaged i agree
um
okay
so how would that work so what that
would have to be
is within the wff directory there would
have to be some hash somewhere
it would have like a metadata file
actually
for the thought that we have some kind
of manifest which would list files and
the attributes
yeah that would probably more robust
than what we were doing or what i was
doing like two years ago which is true
right so okay so then then this
directory then has
include
you know okay so
file names
i don't see any reason to hide the file
names i i think it should be
1.001.002
well actually
should it really be dot i don't think it
should be dot
i think
well what does it actually look like it
says it says foo.jpg.001
is that right let me send you the
implementation i had because it's i
think it's in there
what i was using
just take a look at that
oh yeah by the way i would use start
with zero zero one even if there are
only three of them okay i think it's
clearer
yeah i had something uh
part lowercase dash and an integer
string of some incremented thing with in
base
i don't like
do i really want to look at this code
the
i don't know if you want to but
you don't have to with it
yeah i i had you know something like
like i had part dash and then some
incremental number just to kind of you
know yeah i saw that in the in the
previous implementation but
it does not preserve the file name and
so
went with this scheme
so you can find that would be solved if
you have some sort of manifest file then
you can i think it's all better
i think it's better more robust if
things sort of go wrong
right to have something that looks like
this
now whether it's a dot or a dash at the
end i'm not sure
it doesn't matter it's um just
well it does matter it does matter to
what
look i think something like that might
be nice
and then what we do is
foo dot jpeg
dash manifest
something like that yeah
okay
and that would contain the the original
file name
and it would contain dmd5 sums or
whatever some checksums of individual
yes
although
right okay
so then
okay so let's talk about restartable
file downloading how it actually works
okay so you've created you've turned a
file into a woof
okay
i mean so this then sorry the functions
would be
create
file fragment direct file fragments
directory that's basically the function
right
it's a new name for file partition
that's correct yeah okay
um
and then about the restarting right so
you have to think about say you have a
hundred
pieces right and it goes wrong at piece
13.
right then the code basically has you
know
the the wolfram language code keeps
going right it's just a loop like a
while loop or two loop or whatever right
but
hold on hold on hold on let's say um
import you know read in
or
read in a wff and
reassemble a wff these are
those are two different things right a
very common operation will be there's a
remote woof
and you want to reassemble it locally
okay so so one thing is so reassembling
it locally it will be a rare case that
you already have the woof
locally
do you see what i'm saying that will be
a rare case the more common cases it's
remote and you want to
um
i mean what i'm what i think
will be more common
is
file assemble or something and then what
you give it is http blah blah blah blah
blah
dot wfff
yeah but it can be a local file to it
doesn't matter like any sort of no no no
i i understand that i understand it but
the point is that this
why is this different
from simply let's see how would you get
a file
oh i see this this needs to say where
it's going so this is more like a copy
file
from the woof to some local name
right
sure
or any other
or it can be remote this volume you may
just want to do the whole thing you know
read remote and and put it somewhere
remote
that doesn't matter
the whole point is that to take a wff
and just by convention treat that as a
fragment file file fragments directory
okay now what's the other case the other
case is
that
i want to take that directory
when do you ever return it you never
return i mean you always need to give a
file name does copy file have a default
second argument
um
no
okay so the question is
okay so the the other operation would be
um
you know
i don't know why we've got this
background noise
um
something like this
well file dot
dot
xx dot woof
okay
which then will create the file
assembles
and creates
the file
file.wx now this says what is the thing
for file archive right file unarchive if
i'm remembering what is that what is
that functionality
extract archive
[Music]
to a directory that makes sense here to
to a directory because because you kind
of it's gonna pick the file name already
because that's kind of already embedded
in that roof extension yeah exactly so
you just have to give it a directory
that makes more sense
where do you want the created you know
four gigabyte file to live
it already has a name basically right
so
this is the analog of extract archive
but
it's it's sort of the inverse because
archive is you've got all these files
and you zip them together
right
this says
you could even imagine you take the zip
file
and you woof it
you see what i'm saying
yeah
i mean it's not that's the whole point
like zip files tend to be quite big
right so so the typical thing might look
like the typical file name might be file
dot jpeg
dot zip
dot woof
yeah sandra is commenting about the file
fragments wrapper i don't think we even
need
that wrapper i think we can just say
it's a file extension dot wff is a file
extension
and
you know there's a separate function
that
um
let's see what do we want to do here so
so the issue is this function here
which could be the thing
which is the analog
so the question is is it lazy or not
right so there's two possibilities
you know this is lazy or not
okay so one possibility is it's called
file fragments and it's lazy
do you see what i'm saying
uh no what what does file fragments do
now
it just represents the it represents the
fact that these named files okay so so
okay this this is i'm sorry so there's a
sub case here which is what if
the fragments
are hand curated
maybe we don't even want to consider
that case no that don't do that that
it's all automatic that you can you know
there's there's a set algorithm that you
want to have that you know
right so so two-way algorithm but
there's no hand curation going right
fine okay so so in other words we
we assume
that we have created
the woof
in our own way
yeah
okay so there's no getting inside the
woof is is while you can see it in your
file system as separate files it is
otherwise a single integrated thing
makes sense
right
so
yeah
so we don't allow hand curated
and if it is hand created you just like
a paclet you just put it in that
directory and then that's what you've
got
yep
makes sense
because the algorithm itself may change
over time like we may make it faster or
better and then you know we don't want
to expose you know how these fragments
are created right which means the
manifest constantine needs to have
versioning in it
okay um
i don't know what this clicking noise is
you need to debug this todd please
i'll try but well unless it isn't you
unless it's
constantine nothing's going on here okay
okay
that's what we have a help desk for is
to help debug things like that
okay
so
the case that we don't have here
is
you've got an x a a dot woof file and
all you want to do
no you've got a dot woof directory which
is local
because if it's not local you're going
to want to use copy file i'm making
sense
do you understand what i'm saying hang
on it's not local
sorry
it's url download right copy file
doesn't take urls it doesn't take any
url
i think copy file does yeah it does cop
you know like i mean we have a very
general file
it has a valve
we have a very general file url
concept so you know like that's all
interchangeable like you can just
you can do
whatever okay url download
i see downloads to a temporary file
so
url download if given a woof
would just
download that to a temporary file
assembled
am i making sense
yeah
but that that requires
support from the server side
we can't we can't do that entirely on
our own the
server has to have support if we're
going to do something special for this
wff
no no no no no no no no that's not true
because
the wff file would look for that
manifest file and we just download those
individual fragments
but there's no server support at all
needed for this
well it has all that directory
all the files in that directory have to
be visible all that
yeah but you do that on the server side
with this with a different command with
the create file fragments directory to
command
no i just mean the web server itself you
don't need anything special for the
server no the web server url download
just needs logic that says if it's a wff
file
look for the wff slash yeah yeah
i mean the moment you're going to have
special server modifications that you
you're dead in the world wait wait a
second wait a second in this case what
it has to look for is a file of the form
blah blah blah https or whatever it is
blah blah blah blah
what is it going to actually look for
wff slash manifest something but it
isn't manifest right because it's this
and i don't think you can look for that
in a web server
so i think what you have to do is
actually name the manifest
name it
purely
manifest yeah that's what i'm saying
that's like
something something manifest no but it
isn't something something you can't you
don't know that
oh yes you do it yes
the directory is already unique so you
can just call it manifest.txt it doesn't
matter
no i i understand that but actually you
do already know it
but you don't have to repeat that unique
thing you can just say you know in that
directory okay manifest.here
manifest.txt
yes
okay so then here
url download
automatically looks for
a slash manifest
dot txt
in that directory
yeah for example
right and then that's tells it
literally tells it the names of the
files that it has to download
yeah and some final checks on as well
like you know once you've downloaded and
assembled it and you're gonna you know
check someone it's you you can make sure
that it's correct
right okay and url download already has
the logic to put things in a file and
all that kind of stuff
right
do you see what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that's what it says on the
screen so yeah
yes
okay
so then let's just review for a second
okay so i'm claiming that this case is
irrelevant because i'm claiming that
case
i think that's simply file convert
the rare case where you need it which is
going to be quite rare it's this it's
just a file convert
do you see what i'm saying
um
yeah i don't know what file for it does
but yeah well file convert converts from
one format to another
on as a file you see
okay
okay
and arguably
in the case of uh arguably we could
support a pure file convert with one
argument with just the wolf
okay
okay now
okay
so then
um
all right i think we're covered we're
well covered here
this is good
do you understand why i freaked out guys
about this design review at the
beginning of this meeting
well i wasn't at the beginning of the
meeting well i know you weren't so so
you can't so i missed the excitement
but your your the file assembled which
you're claiming we might not need
is essentially exactly what file joint
is it doesn't have all the same behavior
but it is it doesn't have any you know
built-in notion of
wff but that is the file join yeah it is
it's the same functionality but it seems
like we have to have something that does
a manual assembly and you think file
convert is enough for that i think it's
fine
but the the question is
guys the question again is
do we want okay
okay
this function the function create file
fragments directory
is a very low level thing intended for
download management
there is a quite separate function
okay
let's let's list some other functions
you know
content oriented
fragment file fragmentation file
fragments okay they're different idea
so that's what split does that's what
unix split does
so i'm saying it can do things like
split at a fi at a line
right now that seems to me quite useful
i mean i've i've seen that many times i
would have liked that i end up with a
you know a million line file and i want
to ingest a piece of it
well you you can ingest the piece with
set stream position right i mean i know
but that's okay so so okay so let's
let's use case ingesting
a piece of a large file
okay so set stream position is
unbelievably low level and 35 years old
yeah
that that's the out of core file
processing i think that's a shoddy
project if i remember correctly well
right but i mean i think there's a
minimal version of that which is
okay so that's a that's a bad way to do
it but what if you could say import
and if i could say
you know
import
file fragment
blah blah blah
you know 100 lines
you said what i'm saying
i wouldn't i wouldn't confuse the
don't we do we use the word file
fragment in any of the no we do not okay
wff is a file fragments directory i
don't know the file fragment is the
right
name
but
um i thought there was a whole project
for for out of core file process there
is but it's different from this this is
a much more direct version of that
that's out of core
that is do it all out of core right
do you understand what i'm saying
well
yeah it is no but that's different
that's different that's take the whole
file it's like a snake that's eating a
large animal or something right the the
i don't know that's a very good analogy
you know it moves down no that's a very
bad analogy never mind that analogy the
point is
what out of core processing it's doing
is
it's taking an operation and it is
applying it to the out out-of-core thing
returning an out-of-core result
okay so in other words it's like what we
do with databases it's like saying
instead of operating locally instead of
moving the whole thing into memory and
operating on it
you said i'm saying
yeah yeah okay right right but this is
different this is different this is i
want it in memory i just don't want the
whole thing
and what what does 100 mean like the
first 100 records of that file or
yes yes yes right so this is analogous
to
um
i'm just wondering if i think you can
already do some of that stuff well you
can do it with read string that type of
thing yeah
yeah definitely
with those functions
from the beginning
that's not a good idea
i'm sorry what are you saying
so if you want to give your 100 lines
for somewhere in the middle
uh read string use no it doesn't do the
right thing i i know i know i know i
know i know
um
right my my point here is
this is a useful piece of functionality
to be able to loop over a file saying
you know just import
the middle you know just import you know
the lines that position the hundred
thousand or something
do you get what i'm saying
yeah i i'm just saying that's a
different group of people that that's
sean sheeran and i i know that but i
want to get the design which is a which
is a related design okay
um i understand i understand that but
like
don't design it with me like you're
you're going to get the wrong feedback
if you're going to ask let's just think
about it for a second okay pull out
certain lines
from the middle of a file
right to import
right that's what that's about
okay so if you if you consider it out of
core
and you uh for example it's not out of
core the whole point is it's not out of
core now what i mean is
for that string position you actually
need location specific locations
and that applies to file of
various
formats for example in a video you want
to find the beginning of a video of a
specific
picture
and in the text file you want to you
want a new line positions of new lines
so okay we have a bunch of things for
working with video frames and as you say
it's the wrong group to talk about that
i think i think the the thing that's
coming out of this is we want to have a
discussion
about
text files
and
do you get what i'm saying
about
you know
being able to grab pieces of text files
for import
okay
and that's already easy to do with
it's a little low level but if you open
the stream and then you can read a
hundred lines no no i know i know i know
that means you can implement it
right right what i'm saying
i'm asking for a higher level wrapper
for that functionality
some symbolic representation of the one
to two hundredths line you know record
exactly in a font exactly
exactly
right so so what i'm saying is instead
of file right which says
gulp the whole thing in
right
what i'm suggesting is that
we have something which says import file
section or something
constantine
the reason i'm bringing this up
is because we're about to use the term
file fragments
for something completely different
okay
i think we want to call it something
different from file fragment what's that
right we're not fragmenting a file here
we're simply seeking into a file uh you
know
file piece or
something i mean or file take
their records right file record or
something
like file take but it's a passive so uh
yes i know
that would be a kind of file taking but
that's the wrong
thing i mean if if we if if there was a
noun from that which is taken
so to speak
or that which will be taken i don't know
what the right term is
isn't it really file position
no
it's not file position position returns
a position
and by the way that function might be
useful a file position function
that finds you know i don't think we
have that
find the position find the character
position
of a string in a file
we don't have that which is kind of
shocking but i would have expected we
would have that
that's that's essentially what find
the very old functions find and so on do
you know what i'm saying
well
file take okay so look file
take could be
line-oriented
um
you know that file take could be
i think it'd be more likely a character
character-oriented thing like string
take
a file take is a is an operation it's
not a symbolic representation i know i
know i know i know it could be the
analogue
maybe
segment isn't bad
file segment seems awfully technical
file snippet that's interesting i mean
we have the function snippet
we have a function snippet that does
um
oh my gosh
um
let's see sandra is commenting for
images
how would you do this i think with a
woof there's no problem but with these
kinds of things that's more problematic
and that's where out of core image
um oh file window is interesting
file window is a good idea
except that i worry that we've got other
things about windows but that that does
make some sense that's a that's a
reasonable
uh
file window does sound passive
if you see what i'm saying
um
ethan is sending through something which
says which is a program
split the file into smaller files to fit
on floppies
or in email attachments
when they were flopping around i use
that quite a lot
yes yeah we you know
look we finally lost it with floppies
when the distribution you know the old
mathematica distribution was on like 30
floppies or something
that's the ultimate
file fragment
thing okay but in any case the concept
here
is a file shard is that's an interesting
the problem with shard
i mean shard would be a better name
maybe for these fragments although what
do you think i think fragments is a good
name for these and i really like the
wolf name
for some reason
um
ethan is saying add grep we actually
have a grep like thing it's called
it's very old function that i use with
some frequency it's quite useful
could perhaps do with some overhauling
all right i think we we ran out of time
here um but i think this has been okay
so
this is going to have to be redone a bit
right so this is you know
it's like it's woofs all the way down
and i i'm pretty happy with that design
seems clean
this wolf could be for example a
fragmental uh something like that more
human name
what
instead of wff could be
fragment or
part or something like that
why a human name well i don't know but
what is it no this is a directory
yeah
right
if we call it dot fragments i don't
think it's going to be useful
it has to be
unique
wff is unique
yeah
and you know you just it'll it'll get a
mime type and it'll be you can look it
up i mean
and and it'll mostly be used what does
our download manager use for its file
extension
who knows
somewhere lost inside the download
manager
okay ethan is complaining correctly
probably that the grep the fine doesn't
only works on a single file and he's
right that was not built when we knew
about file system map
that's a good topic and we should we
should discuss that because that's
related to file system map
it's basically a combination of find and
file system map so can can somebody put
that on the ild agenda please yeah no
i'll send it along
um also create file fragments directory
is a bit long and if you drop directory
that will not
yeah i was change the same thing
say file fragments i don't agree with
you i don't agree with you this is not a
consumer function
okay
whoever writes this you write it the one
time you're creating a download manager
i think it's much better to have that
name be completely explicit
i mean if somebody sees this they'll say
that's an obscure internal thing i don't
need it which is the correct answer
right
it seems strange to design a function
with a deliberately obscure name
but uh
i agree that it won't be used by many
right it's not an obscure name it's a
very very clear name it says exactly
what it does
yeah it it's
but it's not like create directory as
opposed to create file fragments that's
what's really what it's about it does
put them in a directory
um i don't really care but
i thought it worked well without the
directory name
yeah um i see us commenting about file
shard integrity checks
let's do a you know if we're going to
create this whole woof thing let's do it
in a sensible way that you know let's
indeed use sort of the best we can with
hashing and cryptography and so on or
not cryptography particularly just
hashing
to um
to make this you know he's commenting on
some kind of file shard integrity checks
yeah fragment integrity right that
checksums on the fragments and that in
the entirety when you re reconstitute it
right i mean there's something kind of
crazy here parity shards saying added to
add redundancy i mean it's like a raid
file system or something but but we
don't
you know
yeah yeah right that's a different issue
that that's an issue which we're not
going to address in the primary version
of a wolf
is
is um
uh
um
it's dealing with you know like a raid
file system whatever piece of it has
been damaged
tough luck we're going to give an error
it seems to me that's something
completely different that's that's it
right that's a redundancy thing which
maybe is some distant future you know
extension of this but for the time being
this is just dealing with assume that we
have good integrity of the file storage
the main issue is transmission
restart and i mean the one thing i think
that needs to be looked at is okay so
when you are downloading when any
operation like url download it's dealing
with a woof it's going to be storing the
pieces in a local directory
and were you to restart that url
download it has to know it has to be
able to see in the same way that local
cache does it
so you should look at local cash
constantine right the same way that
local cash does it it will say i've
already got those pieces
do you get what i'm saying
you could even imagine using local cash
for the pieces well you can use the file
hash right to see if you already have
the right if the file hash is the same
you don't have to re-download everything
i mean then you just have it already
sure but that's how local caching works
yeah
if a user makes a mistake of running the
same command twice no i i understand
that i understand that what i'm saying
is
local cache if what you do is wrap every
instance of a fragment in local cache
then what it will do is it will say is
this is this fragment already downloaded
if yes just use the cache if no download
it and make a cache
do you get what i'm saying
and local cache already has management
of you know the total cache size and all
that kind of stuff but does it check the
hash menu or because i can wrap a
different file with the same name
and it will tell me it will tell me that
i think it i think it checks the hash
but you should check
okay
okay but that's the concept that we want
right so that so that what happens is
you do the url download again
it's going to check hashes and it's
going to make sure that it doesn't
um you know if it needs to download
again it will
but but stephen constantine's not going
to do url download
writing the low level
uh code i know so you've got you guys
have got to communicate with i think
it's devon as project managing here
you've got to communicate with the
people who do
fine
okay
and it becomes an internal function
which can be implemented through file
convert file convert can be its top
level exposure the thing that takes a
woof that has been already downloaded in
its entirety
and
you know
assembles something from that
makes sense
okay
uh
yeah sandra is commenting the wolf used
by some other
god i don't know what's going on with
this background noise i'm getting really
annoyed with it
there
okay i mean we're going to wrap up here
i guess i'll push back the changes that
i made although i consider them largely
irrelevant
right i'm making sense
maybe it's constantly making all this
background noise i don't know
it's coming from somewhere it's quite
here
maybe i'm sorry
it's quite here
okay well
i don't know
now it's quiet so whatever was changed
made it
got rid of that problem
okay all right well
thanks everyone and um
uh let's see oh for people who are yes
we're about to do another design review
about flight tracking data
um which we will also be live streaming
so
we'll
see those who are interested there in a
moment and thank you for the comments
and